now this is trickier and you have to be
careful with that okay I'm gonna pop in
I'm gonna pop in before I draw this
thing I'm just going to normal sign X
because I know what that looks like at
least I should I'm familiar with it and
I can draw this based on that okay so
he's regular sine X okay it's thought it
because not the real graph I'm
interested in now now if I have sine of
not X but sine of X plus 30 what
difference does that make
good I'm shifted and we've gone over
this it's shifted to the left 30 degrees
okay so think about this right if I go
here is 90 degrees right serve roughly
and thinking page decreases about 1/3
the way along looks like it then okay
now that point on the graph should be
moving over this way right in fact I
could draw the whole thing and then just
cut off the parts I don't need look this
regular sine X I've moved it over except
right part of the graph that I've moved
has gone outside the domain and part of
the graph I do need in the domain is
gone now it just so happens because what
doesn't just happen because 0 to 360 is
the exact cycle that sine repeats itself
the part of the graph that's going
outside the domain is exactly the same
part of the graph that I need in the
domain on the other side right so when I
remove it here it reappears over that
makes sense see what I've got there okay
so now I'm looking for where my
solutions are for this is equal to 1/2
okay they have to be careful here you
actually have to draw this with a bit
more accuracy that we've been doing so
far ok what's my first solution going to
be Mike my scale is a bit off actually
I'll try and fix it look something like
my first solution we right there at 0
right 0 and when I draw a cross I get
this ok you have to be careful with this
one because there's my first solution at
0 where's this solution where would have
been had I not had a shift where would
it be
it would have been a 150 we've done this
question family there it is ok but I've
moved everything over 30 years so it'll
be 30 grace left aha
but because I draw this reasonably I'm
missing something our time maybe I
usually get two solutions when I've just
got a normal thing like this right but
because I've moved it over just because
I've moved it over
look if 0 is a solution then every
multiple of 360 ads that is also a
solution right and I have exactly one in
my domain namely 360 and sir
that's a bit sneaky right you'd expect
by baby-daddy you still have two
solutions but in fact you've got one two
three solutions that's a 50
now the great thing about treat at least
through treaty equations is just like
regular equations you can just try it
out you'll like it's a bit weird right
just chuck it in your calculator sign
three-night is sure enough it'll give
you a half if you in case you're not
convinced by the ground
all right now just because I've got it
there I'm going to use this as a thought
exercise to see what would happen if I
just adjusted it a little bit just a
little okay I'm gonna say the same thing
that I said last time which is no you
don't have to do the graphical way but
you must master it eventually so running
away from it now is at best deferring a
school you will need later well if
you're not going to do it now you'll
have to do it later
okay so X is y equals now we can solve
it okay so this is a previous question I
just did okay let's go on the same time
let's go to save them all okay so what
am I gonna do sine X is 40 equals 1/2
I'm still between or 360 now intuition
ought to tell you that my solutions will
be just the same as what I had here
except all of these ones are 10 degrees
too large right let me for instance if I
could put a hundred 20 in here I should
be able to put a hundred and ten in here
and I should get the same thing right
because sine 150 excuse me
sine 120 plus a sine I bring 10 plus 40
right so if this one is 10 degrees too
big if it turns 110
what would this one turn into it would
turn into minus 10 which is outside the
domain okay so I need its equivalent
which is inside the domain which
thankfully I can get from this guy that
make sense
so let me say that again right because
the difference between these two is ten
degrees right it's ten degrees and I'm
adding ten degrees here that are here
okay that means I have to take it off of
this solution cuz it become at the
outside of it so see here sine 120 plus
30 is a solution for this equation right
side 120 plus 30 right so in other words
I've got a total 150 right want to do
the same thing here I can't put for 120
in there with what I'd have to put in a
hundred and ten that would give me a
total of 150 and 350 would do the same
- Tim would do the same except it's
outside the domain okay so my two
solutions that I'm gonna expect are 110
or 300 degrees and you can verify that
by graphing it I'm going a little bit
fed up right so now we're on color now
my line of y equals 1/2 only intersects
twice just like it normally what did
that do man okay